the january 6 committee is making a new
allegation against former president
trump it says there's evidence that
trump called one of the witnesses and
tried to influence that witness it came
during another big day of testimony on
capitol hill and that's where we find
nicole killian once again following it
all for us nicole good morning what more
are we learning
well tony witness tampering is a serious
charge that amounts to obstruction of
justice if proven committee members say
they don't know if a crime was committed
but have referred the matter to the
department of justice which is declining
comment
we will take any effort to influence
witness testimony very seriously vice
chair liz chaney issued another warning
after alleging that former president
trump may have tried to contact a select
committee witness
after our last hearing
president trump
tried to call a witness in our
investigation
a witness you have not yet seen in these
hearings
that person declined to answer or
respond to president trump's call
and instead alerted their lawyer a
spokesperson for the former president
accused cheney of trafficking in
innuendos and lies that go unchallenged
the surprise revelation capped off a
three-hour hearing about how the mob was
mobilized january 6. the panel focused
on a white house meeting december 18
with then president trump in attendance
trump's former national security adviser
michael flynn conservative legal
consultant sydney powell and personal
attorney rudy giuliani the meeting has
been called unhinged
according to witness testimony they were
trying to sell the former president on a
plan to seize voting machines and
appoint powell as special counsel to
investigate voter fraud the committee
says it devolved into a profaned
screaming match that almost came to
blows i'm going to categorically
describe it as
you guys are not tough enough
or maybe i put it another way you're a
bunch of
new video testimony was unveiled from
former white house counsel pat ciboloni
who was also in the meeting the three of
them were really sort of forcefully
attacking
me
verbally and we were one simple question
as a general matter
where is the evidence after the session
broke up trump sent a tweet in the
overnight hours encouraging supporters
to come to washington january 6. he
wrote be there will be wild this tweet
served as a call to action and in some
cases as a call to arms for many of
president trump's most loyal supporters
supporters like steven ayers an ohio man
who recently pleaded guilty for
participating in the riot the president
got everybody riled up
told everybody head on down so he
basically was just following what he
said the committee argued far right
groups like the proud boys and oath
keepers also seized on trump's post what
it was going to be was
an armed revolution i mean people died
that day this could have been the spark
that started a new civil war we fight
like hell after the riders converged on
the capitol even some in trump's orbit
suggested he had gone too far the panel
released text messages between
ex-campaign advisors katrina pearson and
brad parscale who told pearson if i was
trump and knew my rhetoric killed
someone pearson replied it wasn't the
rhetoric parscale replied yes it was
after the hearing witness stephen ayers
who again took part in the riot
approached some of the police officers
in the hearing room who had been
attacked at the capitol and apologized
one of the officers said he didn't hold
a grudge another officer said he did not
accept that apology cbs news has learned
the next hearing will be held in prime
time july 21st and will offer a
minute-by-minute account of what
happened january 6. vlad
all right to be continued nicole thank
you very much as always